a recent report saying nevada is one of
the top states when it comes to
rising rent people all around the valley
noticing those prices going up joel
mohler
live near buffalo and flamingo with more
on the study and reaction
tough for all that rent going up joe
brian that's right people say they're
not surprised by this report they've
been noticing the rent going up over the
past two years and especially
through the pandemic we've been looking
online for about a month just to kind of
get an idea of what's out there
it's a little hard nicole nogriker is
looking to rent a home in the southwest
or green valley two years ago when i
first moved here i found
a house that was pretty easy now it's a
different story
expensive security deposits and higher
rents limits what she can afford
now it's impossible they're not they're
on the market for maybe like two days
three days at a time
people all around the valley are
noticing an uptick in rent a recent
report from online insurance marketplace
quote wizard
shows the average price for a
one-bedroom apartment is up 6.4 percent
over the past two years in nevada
the report listed the top states for
rising rent and nevada is the seventh
fastest
in 2019 the average rent for a one
bedroom in nevada was 930 dollars
now it's dollars las vegas is well over
a thousand
it's expensive it's very expensive megan
blafken moved to upstate new york from
las vegas years ago
she would like to move back to be with
her daughter but says it is impossible
they start at like 900 i'm like
for what i'm paying back here it's gonna
cost like 900 out there and i was like
wow
that's just ungodly
and we took this topic to our eight news
now facebook page where a lot of people
weighed in many people saying their rent
has gone up several hundred dollars we
actually even came across a few people
who actually left
las vegas because rent continues to go
up reporting live near flamingo and
buffalo joe mullen 8 news now